As we discussed, one of the major reason for DNSs vulnerabilities is a lack of
authentication. The DNS sec protocol adds authentication
to DNS responses simply by adding signatures to
the responses that are returned for each DNS reply.
When a stub resolver issues a query, assuming there is no caching, the query is
relayed by the recursive resolver to the root
name server. Which, as we know, sends a referral
to .com, but this referral includes the signature by
the root of the IP address and the public
key of the .com server. As long as this
resolver knows the public key corresponding to the route,
it can check the signature and it knows then,
that the referral is to the correct IP address
for .com. It also now knows the
public key corresponding to the .com server, thus
when the .com server sends the next referral
to Google.com, that referral is signed by .com's
private key. But the root has told the
resolver the public key corresponding to .com, and
thus the resolver can check that this referral
is not bogus and in fact, came from
the .com server. Similarly, the .com server
will return, not only the IP address for
Google.com, but also the IP address and public
key for the Google.com authoritative name server. So
that when Google returns its answers, the
resolver can check the signatures coming from google.com.
In other words, each authoritative name server in
the DNS hierarchy returns not only the referral,
as it would with regular DNS, but also a signature containing the IP address
for that referral. And the public key
for the authoritative name server that corresponds
to that referral. That public key then
allows the resolver to check the signatures
at the next lowest level of the hierarchy, until we finally get to the answer.